yes sir babies Mr on the radar radio Mr
step in step out don't get stepped on
gay P checking in with my brother
bootleg Kev make sure you tapping with
my boy he's showing love he's holding it
down you already know what it is
that's not the plan yeah
podcast special guest in here on the
radar Zone my guy Gabe yes sir my God
pleasure to be here man first of all
nice yeah nice to finally get up with
you man uh I was telling you we met real
quick at the BT media house this weekend
um but I'm gonna give you your flowers
because uh the no jumper interview that
you had did with Adam like a long time
ago well no it was like a year ago like
a year and a half like a year and a half
ago I really like watched and dissected
that interview so much because a lot of
the stuff that you were going through
with this podcast is like I felt like I
was also going through at the times with
on the radar you know being affiliated
with a radio station but your podcast
not entirely being affiliated with the
station and you know just having that
like Synergy and and a lot of the things
you said in in that like kind of really
helped me and kind of like my thought
process of like okay this is how I
should move with on the radar going
forward too so I want to thank you for
that all good man so for people who
don't know so your roots are in radio
yes my return radio I started off at uh
St John's in Queens
um with uh along with Nyla who's also on
power
um Angie Martinez came to the radio
station for her book tour me and her
both interviewed her and then the rest
is like pretty much history and you
picked this up like took a liking to you
guys yeah yeah and you took a liking to
us she uh literally just picked us up
out of the radio station and um and then
brought us to power 105. and then I was
an intern at Power 105 for the rest of
my college career until like pretty much
right before I graduated
um and then I I took a full-time
position as like the I ran all their
social media so I took a full-time
position before I graduated to stay in
the building she was a social guy I was
Association officially yeah I was a
social guy at the station before
anything so I ran the social media up
until last August when I when I left
because you know yeah everything was
going was doing and then you were doing
weren't you doing like um something with
Charlemagne Marvel uh yeah yeah podcast
yeah we had um a few episodes you guys
didn't do too many episodes we did like
17. that's a lot yeah we did like 17 it
was called Comic Kings and it was just
good that like had spawn out of um when
I was an intern Charlemagne and I would
just talk about like the different comic
book movies that we were watching so
like I think I remember like one
conversation me and him had it was like
Logan had came out and uh we were just
having a debate about the movie and then
somebody had to say she's like yeah I
should do a podcast together so like you
know on my time off and his time off you
know after breakfast club we would just
shoot it and then the pandemic came and
then he got his show and then everything
just kind of got super busy but honestly
like that was such a great opportunity
and and it's when we still see each
other like we talk about like the nerd
[__] like we love that what'd you think
of flash I didn't get to see it yet
because I've been on we you know we've
been on the on the radar tour it's like
super mid yeah I keep hearing I'm like
how Michael Keaton did it what's that
what how'd they [__] that up like like
how do you bring back like everybody
well most people's favorite Batman right
right and then you include Supergirl and
then somehow you still mess it up it's
like this this guy who plays flash did
so many so much WoW [__] and they kept
him in the movie uh so I'm like they had
to kept them in there because it has to
be fire I was thinking they were
scrapping after this guy was like
breaking into people's houses and
falling asleep on the couch and doing
all kinds of weird [__] the actor or
like fight or like fighting people in
home you guys a [__] Wild guy for
sure you ever seen the video of him in
Hawaii where it's like um you know what
you're trying to talk about was it like
his face also I'm not sure I think he's
uh they slashed them they yeah they they
sorry it's Gotta Be My apologically
correct gotta be correct but when um
they had uh when their uh their mug shot
was on the TV yes and then it pans over
and he's just like sipping a drink in
like a nice in like a nice suit talking
to three older women this is like a wild
boy man wow boy but yeah I didn't get to
see it I'm gonna watch it uh when I go
back to New York but I I did see spider
verse and spider-verse was phenomenal
amazing do you think do you think the
spider-verse uh two movies are better
because there's a lot of people saying
that they're the best Spider-Mans period
yeah I think so you think so I think so
I just think it's just I don't know I
remember when the anime movies first
came out I was like I don't want this
like when like when they announced it I
was like I don't want miles I like I
want to see miles you know an actor yeah
like live action because he's Puerto
Rican I'm Puerto Rican you know what I'm
saying so I'm like okay this is dope
because you know we're gonna get like
we're getting first of all afro Latino
representation on the big screen he's
from Brooklyn my family's from Brooklyn
like it just kind of felt like okay this
is dope but then like when it actually
came out like into the spider-verse
between became like one of my favorite
superhero movies of all time and I think
the two of them alone are really the
best Spider-Man movies ever created and
it's weird because it's animated so you
wouldn't normally think that but I like
I like the new one way better than I
like like the Tom Holland ones for sure
I've I think I agree with you man the
time you know what the one is that last
time Holland won when the it's just got
that one moment where all the Spider-Man
come together and you're just like
it's like this is crazy like but have
you re-watched it like after the fact
yeah it's not as great when you re-watch
it for sure you're right like it's like
it's just like one of those in-theater
moments that you remember almost like a
end game you know what I'm saying like
it's it's but yeah the spider-verse [__]
is lit so let's get to uh you you
obviously build this platform yeah
um was on the radar uh
uh something that you had always kind of
like
because I I think early on I was seeing
you were doing stuff during the pandemic
on like Zoom yep and which everybody was
doing right we all had to do that
um when did you initially did you launch
on the radar during the pandemic or was
it prior to the pandemic like give me
the the kind of the history well like
all the radar started in in 2018 so like
I originally had the idea because for me
like you know I'm 26 so I'll 2018 I was
like I was like 21 22-ish and my biggest
thing for me back then was like I you
know I was a young kid and and I was
listening to like you know the little
Uzi versus yachties and and the whatnot
and I would see them go on different
platforms and I just felt like they
weren't really understood by you know
you think about like the infamous Joe
Budden moment with him and yachty and
it's like even like the Ebro one where
they were like trying to give him a rap
over some Primo [__] right and I don't
necessarily blame them for those moments
you know what I'm saying because you
know they just didn't understand that's
their generation right you know what I'm
saying they're younger kids right so I
felt like at that time I was like damn
like I don't really see them I'm being
represented properly in a media space
and I didn't really see anybody
um in my age really being able to be in
this media space and also kind of be
that kind of that like that person
that's able to grab them and help them
you know be presented properly the way
that like you know you think of like an
Angie Martinez in the 90s wait
um with everybody from New York right or
you think of uh or bless you or you
think of um who am I thinking of um
Columbia radio station I don't know why
I'm blanking right now she's in my
stretching button yeah stretching babito
right like or how stretching babito was
there to help bring up biggie uh Wu-Tang
like they had like some of their first
three songs
you think about those and like I wanted
to do something like that for this
generation so I came up with the idea
um back in in like December of 2018
right after I graduated college you know
I kind of were you already at Power yeah
I was already full-time on on um on the
digital side of things I was part of the
Angie Martinez show I helped out with
Breakfast Club so I did a little bit of
everything and and when it came to like
creating this space I was like you know
I wanted it to be like on the radio
station but they were like you know it's
building on your own you know what I'm
saying like kind of started getting
going they had a room there that I could
use it was the same room that
Charlemagne used to film brilliant
idiots in so I was just filming like one
interview a day right or like one
interview a week something like that and
it was just I was Finding anybody and
anybody and everybody I can interview
just trying to start building my
connection so I was doing that for a
while and then I started making more
younger friends in the industry
um and that's how I ended up getting up
some bigger artists are getting a little
more recognition in New York and then
the pandemic came and like right before
the pandemic I did this interview with
uh bankroll Freddie and like that was
kind of like my biggest interview at the
time I had like I think I had like 20
000 views like in like a week or
whatever which was like a lot for me at
the time right and I was like okay cool
I have all this traction but now like
everything is shutting down dead right
so I was like in a space where it was
weird because I also had another show at
the time I did with power called uh
enter player two which was like a video
game show so I'll play uh like Mortal
Kombat 2K with like some artist like I
had Chef G and Sleepy Hollow on that
show too which was like one of their
most talkative interviews which was
really dope at the time right so
pandemic came I'm like and I was like
damn what do I do now like I really
don't know what to do
um the zoom interviews came around and
then like I kind of got out of this like
you know depressive state that I was in
not knowing where to go in my show just
having to do the Social Media stuff
every single day which was like it was
fine but it's like it's not what I love
to do right
um and I just started doing like two to
three Zoom interviews like every day
like I was just like you know what
anybody again anybody and everybody who
I could connect with in any place in the
world I'm gonna do I'ma figure it out so
I was doing interviews with um with
people like some afrobeat artists like I
did Stone boy very early on
um in my career and then I was doing
like people from like the Carolinas
Florida like literally anybody that I
could do a zoom interview with
um and then it kind of came to a point
where it was like we had I figured out
this rhythm with the content I'm like
okay I think I know what I'm doing now
and we started you know getting out of
the pandemic and I was like you know I
want to do live interviews so I started
doing those again and and I came up with
I had always had this idea for
freestyles on the show and I had done
them kind of ghetto before like I would
have my laptop literally sitting right
here plug the headphones into the laptop
and then I would put the volume all the
way up let them wrap and then in
post-production I would try to hear
where the beat started and I'll try to
match it up that's [__] crazy super
super ghetto right but it worked it
worked it worked I only had like one or
two that I couldn't put out because of
that so we had that done and then I
found this spot well because you guys
had freestyles where they weren't
wearing headphones sometimes right am I
tripping no we always have okay maybe
I'm tripping I just saw somebody
freestyling there was no headphones on
and I was like no somebody somebody [__]
there was I was like what is going on
here they don't have headphones on where
they hearing the beat like actually okay
there was one there was one um we do we
had like some ciphers like we did a
Christmas Cipher we called it the uh
Christmas and Harlem Cipher I remember
seeing that you guys had like a [__]
78 people rap yeah yeah we had like 16
people rapping that that was that was a
really dope moment too but that that we
had like a speaker outside
um and they could hear it same with the
ladies night that we just did in Atlanta
we that one had a we had a uh an
external speaker that they could hear
the beat played off of it's gonna have
he would just handle the yeah my
producer Rob is like a magician with
that I don't even know how he does it
but he he finesses it but we started
doing the freestyles
um like kind of shortly after like I
kind of caught the wave of the drill
scene like I had caught you know k-flog
be love and Dougie B I did their first
interview together
um I did Dusty Locane busy banks around
that time and then I was like all right
I got this motion doing these interviews
what else Bobby Fischer guys yeah Bobby
shout out Bobby man shout out Bobby bro
um but yeah so then like I found this
spot called hmd Studios out in uh
Brooklyn which is you know sadly closing
its doors really soon
um but that's kind of where we started
doing the freestyles and I just like I
have my producer Rob who I mentioned at
the time and I'm like bro we're doing
all these interviews with like these
Dope Up And Coming artists I'm like can
we do freestyles here and he called over
the owners to the studio and who are
also friends of mine he's like is this
possible and they're like yeah this is
possible so we started off just kind of
like doing again once again like anybody
who wanted to come rap
just bring them to come wrap pull up and
one of the first people who I had come
wrap on my on the freestyles and that
studio was Lola Brook because me and
Lola had done interviews before so we
had this relationship and then kind of
from there we just kind of caught this
wave we caught the drill wave in New
York and then I mean yeah freestyle yeah
I spices [__] which was not sure she'll
ever do another one of those ever again
hey man look if I have the only ice
spice free if I have the only ice spice
freestyle ever I'll be happy I'll be
happy but like you know we caught a lot
of really dope incredible artists early
on and I feel like you know that's kind
of where I wanted to be at in 2018.
um I it took it took a bit of time but
like you know I feel like a lot of young
people in this industry don't always
realize how long things take and you
guys
so when we started doing freestyles for
the podcast we kind of started the same
way I think because we were thinking of
the monetization route so I would have
my producer Tony chock just give me a
beat yeah that was original that
wouldn't get flagged so a lot of your
guys's beats are from producers that
let's not like
they're freestyling over like pound town
you know what I'm saying like yeah his
original instrument instrumentals right
some cases yeah I mean you know I kind
of like to give the artists a free range
to do what they what they want
um we do have a lot of we have in-house
producers now uh my boy Fritz Cooks up a
lot of the beets um Hitman gave us the
beat for the ladies night Cypher so that
was really dope but I try to give them
the free range you know um I got a great
partnership with create on the
monetization side of things so they
helped me kind of sort through all those
things with the beats and kind of like
getting copyrights on
um are you guys putting all the
freestyles on like Spotify and all that
[__] not all of them but we have a lot
like we put out
um like what 115 already this year
115 already this year so we have like
entire we have a pretty big catalog that
we just dropped this year alone but we
try to encourage artists now especially
the up and coming ones it's like look if
you coming on the show you might as well
do an original beat so we can put you in
our ecosystem on streaming and then you
get the on the radar fans we get your
fans and then we kind of are able to
marry that together 100 so for you like
uh
you say how were you with Angie like
every day like Monday through Friday
yeah every day for many years what was
the because Angie's obviously I've met
her a few times and she always is so
[__] like you know I was when I
before I met her I was just assuming she
had this Aura around her but she's so
nice like yeah she's like super super
super super sweetheart what was um for
you being around the voice of New York
what'd you learn man would you take away
the one thing I'm sure you learned a
million things but you know I'm sure uh
is there one or two things that you kind
of apply to what you're doing right now
I feel like the one thing that I always
tell people I took away from being
around Angie was like how important
relationships are in this industry right
and I learned this with Angie when I was
working her digital side like you know
like if I'm trying to think of it like
let's say like I I worked the six nine
interview for an example right like I
would think about like I thought from a
young person's perspective I'm like what
headline can we put this on YouTube that
will get the most clicks and then Angie
would always reiterate to me it's not
about always is what's going to get you
the most clicks but like or like what
can what's going to be messy or what's
this but she's like you got to remember
that like building relationships over
time is important she's like you know
you don't want to just go right for the
click bait stuff and then you you burn a
bridge with somebody right and and as I
got older I started realizing how
important that is because a lot of the
you know media now oftentimes we you
know people want to go right for
clickbaity headlines for sure that
um but then it does you don't you know
those same you know YouTube Pages or
whatever like they don't think about
like the long term
um implications of that you know you
kind of burn Bridges or you don't you
burn relationships and I just you know I
remember I was at a party I think for it
was like Angie and Angela Yee's like day
off I think that's what they called it
and it was like in the winter time it
was around their birthdays and I
remember just seeing like everybody in
the room with them like I saw like Joe
and a bunch of other like people who've
just been around them for x amount of
years and I'm like you know you think
about the relationships that they built
over these periods of time and how they
wouldn't be around now
if they had you know had like that click
bait mentality like oh I gotta ask them
some crazy [__] just to get you know
100K views because sometimes those 100K
views ain't worth the relationship being
broken you know I'd rather I tell ours
all the time like I'd rather mess with
y'all for like five to ten years and
let's do this a million times and me
just get 100K views off you one time and
then now we beefing we don't like each
other no more yeah I've had that I just
went on back on fig man and [__]
whoever T Rose guy is [__] mislabeled
some clip and I had to hit him like bro
this did this wasn't said like what is
that yeah he's like bro my bad let me
fix it but I I just yeah I think I think
you know there's definitely for you I
feel like you you don't do messy [__]
which is important you know yeah and we
try not to do messy [__] over here I
mean we just interviewed Christian rock
and blueface or not Christian rock uh
blueface in his uh baby moms yeah Alexis
yeah I was watching that before I came
here that was messy for sure that was
definitely but that's not you trying to
be messy like you're just doing the
interview like it's like you're not the
messy one then in this case you're just
asking questions that people want to
know for sure and it's not like it's not
like you're not purposely like I mean at
the end of the day like it's an
interesting conversation like right
we're the first interview that do both
of them together and like people are
interested in in them you know no matter
how many times I mute I mute blueface's
name from my timeline somehow oh it's
pop it's Chris I always pop back up it
will always pop up man
um so what do you really kind of
remember like what video for you kind of
made you realize like oh there's
something here that like I can leave uh
I was about to say hi 97 damn sorry
sorry Thea
um lead Power 105 and and and kind of
just go full time with your own [__]
well I'm still at Power I still do my
radio shows at power but like leaving my
I'm talking about your full-time yeah
the full-time job yeah you're doing the
social media director thing because yeah
you you the show's on the air right yeah
it shows on Friday nights as well too
yeah I uh you know I think it was really
kind of when the motion started going on
when we caught the the second wave of
drill music with like K flocking them in
the Bronx like that's when I was like
okay there's something here that we can
really tap into and then it was just
kind of like over time like the reason
why I had to leave that position it was
just like
you know I caught myself at times being
like I like I don't care about this as
much as I care about on the radar you
know what I'm saying like I I wasn't in
like the most like financially stable
place where I was like okay like I could
do on the radar full time but like it
was getting to the point where my brain
couldn't handle doing this other job and
doing on the radar and it kind of like
felt like to the point where it's like
not that I'm wasting I didn't feel like
I was wasting my time doing that
position but it felt like that energy
that I'm doing at that the energy I was
given that job if I put it into on the
radar I could go you know and and you
know everybody at at Power was very
supportive of that decision like they're
like look man like you have something
special you know I think you should you
should you know take the chance on it
and then it was just like you know we
went with it and you know we we caught
that drill wave early we caught like you
know like you said the ice spices the D
things you had the four one got you had
yeah
uh Kyle up here yeah that freestyle for
y'all it was crazy 16m yeah yeah wow 16
mm it's crazy yeah but you know
on dsps
um that one isn't they kind of they
turned two of those records I think into
songs but not every piece of that was
ever released on streaming
um but that's also something we learned
early on too that you know that we all
kind of we don't regret it now but like
now when you look back at it
um in 2023 like it's like damn like if
we kind of had our [__] together the way
that we have now with streaming services
that could have just gone same with ice
spice like we probably could have gotten
ice spices
um freestyle on streaming if this was
you know a year and a half ago before
she blew up but I think that's all part
of the learning process you know I wish
I could have had these on streaming I
wish I could have these records under my
name but you never know man like you
know like you said like you gotta you
gotta learn as you go brother like this
[__] is there's no there's no road map
to this [__] so yeah gotta stop the
interview to say about our good Folks at
Odd Socks baby yeah shout out to odd
talks now this is what I love about Odd
Socks one their family we love them but
also they have the most comfortable
socks in the [__] world all right now
look they got the craziest licenses you
see the Jolly Rancher these are actually
flies [__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the Odd Socks Basics now
these are just the basic socks so these
are in my bag because I'm taking these
I love these Odd Socks basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shout out to the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps uh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview
um the drill [__] is so like it feels
like from like a guy who lives in L.A
because I've gone out there we hung out
with uh we hung out with Dusty we hung
out with yeah uh who else
a bunch of those guys yeah
um but obviously the the rep is is a
very violent divisive genre of music
right
um
do you have you ever got wrapped up in
any of the [__] just because I'm sure
you gotta be kind of play friends with
everybody right of course is it because
and do you think it's a lot a lot of
it's overstated
um there well I got a few opinions on
that well like the one thing I got
caught up in was like when you know
there was like a point where I was like
all right like y'all doing too much like
this one on my show like I'm not trying
to do all this right right so I I like
made a statement where
um that I caught a lot of flack for like
from people this like a year ago where I
was like look I think I remember that
you said like no more diss anybody no
more name dropping right and if you do
name drop it's gonna get x'd out right
because I'm not trying to do I want to
add to that right I don't I'm not trying
to add to that I'm not trying to politic
with that and I but I still want to
support y'all because I believe in a lot
of them right you feel me and I caught a
lot of flack for that but over time like
you know like anything you just write
out the wave and it's cool you know what
I'm saying like nobody really is like is
like upset by that anymore they're like
oh why can't I do the white guys I'm
like I'm not gonna let you use my
platform as a way to like go at y'all
right right there's other platforms that
you could go do that on go do that on
that platform this is like you know if
you want to create like the corner store
like the perfect Cornerstone hip-hop
platform like I don't want it to be
known for that right
um so like that part but I feel like you
know when it comes to like the music
itself is like these kids like this is
what they really live in and I feel like
me like I think Rob Markman had also
said on like rotation uh Roundtable to
show that I do on Amazon he was like
look man he's like if you really
listening to a lot of like you know
gangster rap lyrics from like 90s early
2000s like if you listen to like the
locks like they they say in some of the
same [__] that these kids are saying
they just saying it differently like
definitely now it's more like
um
I feel like it's more detailed for sure
but also it's not that far from what
we've already gotten in the past you
feel me and again like these kids like
this is their real life situations and
that's and you know it just feels more
like you said not only the detail aspect
of it but we also like back then we
didn't have social media so like
[__] were going live on
people's blocks and like it just feels
like now it's like man these guys are
really doing some [__] on the internet
then going and rapping about it and then
getting arrested for it and then getting
sentenced like no it's definitely dumb
like like it's definitely dumb how they
put everything on the internet right
I've been thinking about like if the
internet was around back then like it'd
be it'd be a wild place because then you
had hip-hop police back then and I'm
sure there's hip-hop police now but back
then it was like there was like a whole
task force like right obviously like I
was even just watching this video on the
way here it was like 50 Cent I forgot
what BET Awards it was but it was like
you know they're like 50 was a wild boy
like he didn't wrap the whole first
verse of his song walked around the
arena waiting to see if if any of his
like Ops or whoever would do something
and like you know and they're like and
what was the caption was like oh the BT
Awards need to start bringing rappers
back to the BT Awards who beef with each
other you know what I'm saying no and I
was like first of all terrible idea
terrible idea but at the same time it's
like but I think about like okay that
was 50 back then now and that's without
the internet so imagine if like I would
have been all over academics and shade
room and right so it's like it's not
that much you know when people criticize
or you know the last generation
criticizes this generation for what they
do I think it's just like you gotta look
in the mirror and be like look if social
media was around when you guys were
outside doing what y'all was doing it's
like it it wouldn't really be that
different we're all human at the end of
the day like I wouldn't be surprised if
back then you would see like somebody on
IG live talking oh ah like oh no no if
the internet was not around so it's like
it's different bro it's like [__] when
50 first came out I'm not even sure my
space was popping like that definitely
not definitely not but it's like yeah
it's different different world
everything like everything's online and
then also the pressure of like having I
look like a [__] because you're on the
internet comes into people reacting
maybe if they wouldn't have reacted had
they not realized that the whole world
will see how they would react you know
what I'm saying right but would I be
telling them too I'd be like look like
sometimes like with the music that y'all
make is like you have to remember that
the music that you make like it's not
just people and if we're talking
strictly from a New York drill
perspective it's like it's not even just
like the music people in New York aren't
just seeing this like people all around
the country are seeing this and like
that affects your money at the end of
the day too because someone from you
know you're talking from like a West
Coast perspective if you hear them
talking crazy just an X Y and Z is like
and you're a promoter or you're a show
book or whatever your Live Nation it's
like I don't know if I want to book
these well even like the rolling loud
[__] like guys was getting like they
were getting banned from like Ron soon
uh I think Dougie B2 and like it's like
I'm like some of this stuff and Ronson
didn't I don't know why they did that
Toronto but like all this stuff can
affect your money at the end of your
longevity so like let's say you have
like the biggest disrecord in the world
great but like
if how but like are you worth a
liability for me to book you yeah what
at what cost like like it got you lit
amazing congratulations I think that
that's great for you but like at what
cost is at what cost does it then affect
the rest of your money now because now
people for the rest of time will be like
I don't know because they a liability
because you know I don't want him coming
to LA and then right the people that
they're talking about move to LA too and
then now they the people they talking
about trying to get somebody to come
through I mean like if you think about
the nationally biggest people
obviously pop smoke rest in peace rest
in peace pop but pivoted into and I
don't even he didn't even get to see the
success of his pivot sonically
um
504 and you know doing a record with
Alicia and like not necessarily leaning
on that [__] and then even like I mean
nice spice is rapping over drill [__]
you know what I'm saying like yeah she's
a pop star it's kind of crazy it's like
really crazy yeah I spice is the closest
thing that I've ever seen that if
someone said that industry plans for a
real which they're not I don't believe
that I don't believe that either yeah
that's not a real thing but if there was
like some like internet rap conspiracy
that I spice was an industry plan I'd be
like I understand why you think that
right because it is just like
it's crazy has she done an interview
besides you yeah oh yeah yeah she's like
breakfast club or anything she she
hasn't done she did Ebro on Apple on
Apple one but she hasn't been like like
the traditional hot 97. she did hot she
did oh yeah she didn't want to out but
it wasn't like super and he couldn't do
a lot of interviews I noticed that too
it's probably smart not to over expose
yourself yeah I think like you know you
know what you were saying about like the
the wait pop like first of all like the
fact that pop is still probably the most
streamed artist in New York in terms of
younger artists and it bro in L.A this
[__] non-stop every single power
rotation for like two years straight I'm
talking about like what you know about
love is still like a sub power in La
yeah it's crazy like and it's it sucks
because he didn't get to see yeah you
know the fruits of his labor 100 you
know like I feel like
part two of the uh what was the EP that
he put out was it the um before he died
it was the oh um
that was the last piece of work I think
that yeah before he passed literally
like two weeks yeah and then this
[__] album drops and it's like just
hit record after hit record and it's
like and it's crazy because this is like
the album that dropped probably that was
I don't know I was I they did something
called where they played a project I
don't know if they said it was 60 done
before he passed away or something like
that but like you imagine it's like okay
what if you actually finished still
around and he was here to finish these
records and had the features on it that
he wanted you know not saying that they
put all those features on there because
I think 50 did a great job of like
executive producing and same because
like yeah this the because the last
album was cool but it was definitely
you're like oh this this was like
super unfinished stuff that they just
pulled together and there were so many
random features and [__] and yeah one of
my one of my man's produced one of the
songs on on on that on on that project
and then they switched they like
switched the beat on him see like that
kind of shit's like you know or like um
they had two songs on there the one with
busy Banks and the one with Ross wish
those were songs that were 100 finished
before he passed away 100 finished and
they changed him no no they let him kept
him but you could tell like when you
listen to the project you can kind of
tell what records were there before he
passed away versus what was kind of like
kind of Frankenstein together after the
fact and like that sucks to me like and
I heard stories like his friends versus
getting taken away from him and stuff
like that like and I I don't like [__]
like that because I'm like look like he
was trying to put his P like pop was
always about putting his people like if
you watch all these interviews with him
especially the Angie interview he talked
about Chef he talked about sleepy I
think he talked about busy in there he
talked about Ross wish trying to think
well but like he was always about
putting like people who he [__] with
on so like I think that that's just
unfortunate that we got to a point where
it's like okay now we're just gonna
we're gonna throw this pop verse here
you know what I'm saying like I know
there's one on negos album I don't know
where that came from like right right I
think about things like that and that
[__] kind of sucks Tiger's got hella
versus
oh Pop versus I think he's got one or
two out I'm like Tyga he got the
sunshine one the one with him sunshine I
feel like there was another one though
or am I tripping no I'm thinking Tyga
and him had a record together on oh yeah
yeah I liked West Coast [__] that was a
good school yeah but yeah like you think
about like I don't know I don't know if
Sunshine was done before pop passed away
or not I'm not gonna I don't know the
story behind that record but like if it
was Frankenstein together it's like damn
like they did a good job they did a good
job Frank is signing that one together
but it was kind of sad yeah um I was
gonna ask you like uh so this
complex list comes out right okay uh
this is this is the headline okay no I'm
just curious because like I feel like
you're very like to like you I I mean
I'll be honest with you I feel like
you're the premier freestyle platform
now I feel like you you guys what you
guys are doing is more important than
what the leakers do
um Flex is flex you know so Flex is
gonna get like yeah he Legend regardless
the Conway [__] that just happened was
crazy like I mean I still watch the
Black Thought one like once a week the
Meek Mill ones are obviously Meek Mill
and the Tory Lanez ones I always watch
um but I was gonna say for you like you
know we do we do freestyles here we drop
like two two probably one or two a week
it just depends on what happens here but
like you guys have really dug your heels
into the freestyle Lane and it's it's
been dope to see because I feel like
like you said like being in New York
there is like you can't you can't just
be anybody and go see Flex you know what
I'm saying yeah like you gotta have a
certain It's gotta make sense for him
right you know what I mean for you
you're giving people platforms that you
just believe in or that you're like hey
I think this person's dope I think more
people should have eyes on these on this
person absolutely
um so do you do when you see like a list
like that come out do you feel like you
deserve more acknowledgment when it
comes to certain [__] like that or you
do I mean you still like a relatively
new platform but like what are your
thoughts on that kind of [__] I mean
obviously like you know
I'm like first of all thank you for the
for the for the kind words and like also
kind of just going off what you said
about giving people a chance like the
one thing I want to say about on the
radar is I like the reason why on the
radar is what it is is because my goal
for it is to be able for you to have a
Meek Mill or a little baby on there but
then also a little homie from down the
block right you know me because I feel
like there's no place where you marry
all those things into one place that's
just about the culture about hip-hop
about music in general right
um but when I see things like that like
of course like I'm like man like you
know I was bummed out about it but like
I've been the underdog for so long in my
life and in my career that like it
doesn't phase me because I know you know
the numbers are like like I don't like
to be the person like look at the
numbers but the numbers are there you
feel me like we're doing things that
hasn't really been seen in a long time
and hasn't you know there is no platform
since like I feel like like a rap city
that or like 106 and Park that's or TRL
that's really kind of brought like the
up and coming and like the who's hot at
the same time right the fact that I can
go on my show and like bro from down the
block was there and as he's walking out
Emily Chapa is walking in like that's
fire right you know what I'm saying like
nobody's doing something like that or
like sexy Reds walking walking in as
like this up-and-coming R B singer from
jerseys is is leaving like that's dope
so of course like I see that on my damn
like this is crazy like I feel like we
deserve the recognition it was funny
because when that list came out
um that same night I was at like this
DeVito uh event at like Legos and uh and
like then they complex posted like the
up next like list thing they're like oh
hip-hop's next like whatever I forgot
what they called it but it was just like
it was just like a social post and it
was like me Hakeem from ogm
um don't call me white girl I'm trying
to think well there are a few other
people on that list but I'm like all
right so I'm a social post you know what
I'm saying but I appreciate all the
recognition regardless because I know
that like it's gonna be there right one
way or another but also like I just be
getting tired of the list too also this
[__] doesn't really matter it doesn't
like help it's like like you said check
to check the scoreboard you know what
I'm saying like yeah so like like I had
people hitting me like and I genuinely
just didn't care like yeah how did you
feel about that I didn't give a [__] bro
like I really didn't expect to be on the
list like we're over here in La we are
very independent operation
I don't care about none of that [__] bro
like they try to uh get me to like be
angry on so whose show was on when they
asked me about it
t-real [__] oh tea rose I just did I
just like I have no emotion man like my
whole thing towards it is like you know
at the end of the day like I'm doing me
if people want to recognize it it's cool
if not
we're gonna be all right like yeah
that's how I feel shit's moving yeah we
good because I feel like it's just like
you know people love making these lists
right and also I it's a buy it's also
that's why I surprise you in because I
mean listen complex the East Coast buys
place right so I was really thinking
like how's the [__] going on over
there thing like you've had more moments
than a lot of these [__] right
saying like and you do it with the high
integrity you know what I mean yeah and
complex stirring up [__] you know
yeah complex sodas has shown us mad love
like we just had two freestyles on like
the top 25 verses of the year so far
um and they've done like other stuff
with me before so but I didn't feel no
way because of that like I wasn't I
didn't hit my man's at complex like yo
bro why you ain't put me I would never
do that because I don't I don't think
that's a you know that's an Integrity
thing like I would never handle business
like that or come out my neck at someone
like that because that's not how I am
but you know at the end days like you
know you still are disappointed you're
like damn I wish I could have been
recognized by this but it's like it's
cool because I just kind of turn all
that fuel into motivation like whenever
they told me oh like you know you won't
be able to have this this artist all
right cool I'll see you in a year right
and like you know then we then they end
up coming back around anyway because now
they're like okay cool like you know
we'll have an artist who comes on the
show and we'll do an interview they're
like I don't know if I want a freestyle
and I'm like I I'll see you and I'll see
you in six months and then six months
later yo hey let's stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our good
Folks at King Palm that's right man
shout out to King Palm uh we're talking
about nothing but that organic all right
that natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg Kev try either one of those I
forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discreetly of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going and
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you could tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right blueshear.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're going to give you
a month's supply for free just five
dollar shipping bootry.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview is it hard because you you'll
get freestyles from artists who
traditionally don't do freestyles right
yeah so do they go there knowing they're
going to Freestyle because a lot of
times we'll run into that where like
somebody will come to LA and they'll
have like their La leaker [__] ready
yeah and obviously that well I'm valet
leakers ain't a thing anymore y'all
breaking news
um they're just incredible thing ready
um and uh you know like we're we're not
like our brand isn't freestyle driven we
do freestyles yeah but it's not like you
know we do both you know what I mean
where I would say we're more known for
interviews you know of course it is so
like
I gotta hit artist sometimes to be like
hey I know you come to La make sure you
got the other clip ready you know what I
mean like save me something you know
what I mean but but y'all I feel like
now if people come to New York like
they're coming there to do your [__]
yeah I think you know even like because
Flex is a lot harder to get onto you
know what I mean like absolutely yeah so
like do you do you guys have those
conversations like hey look just just do
something man if you like it we'll use
it if not we'll scrap it like oh hell
yeah we definitely have those combos
like I also give artists like the
opportunity like look if you don't want
to do a freestyle like let's get a
performance video out of you yeah dude I
know you all do that like you did the
sexy red performance exactly yeah which
which one of the funniest things we ever
shot too but like Anna Lee Chopper did a
performance with uh his Duda Gino that's
two times four times I'm sorry if I say
that wrong bro uh I'm sorry but like he
did a performance off the deluxe off of
uh Cottonwood too which is totally cool
because it still went crazy regardless
because at the end of the day not a lot
of people knew that song so a lot of
people in the comments like oh this is a
fire freestyle even though it's people
don't know how to read two by the way
it's like it says performance at the
bottom but regardless but I just try to
get something out I'm like look if you
don't like it maybe come do a lip sync
of like a song that you have on the
project like like something let's just
do something you know what I'm saying
because I like maximizing content like
you're there you're there for an hour
it's like a 20 30 minute interview
sometimes depending how talkative you
are and then you know then if you do a
lip sync it takes like 10 minutes not
even to get that done
um but you know most people already know
like if but if I had a dollar bro for
like how many freestyles we haven't
released to or like you know haven't
come out like you know I'd be rich by
now what is don't tell me who did it but
what was the because we've had some very
long freestyle sessions where
[__] will take like 30 takes oh
yeah okay okay where it's like crazy
like I think there was like one time we
had someone who was in here for like an
hour and I literally was like look man I
got [__] to do so this is your final go
and they got it what was the longest you
had to wait for someone to nail their
[__] why are you laughing bro I hear you
in the back no I'm not gonna say no name
no don't say the name don't say that
yeah you know me I'm not gonna do that
but uh it was actually pretty it was
actually within the last six months
there was one that we stopped laughing
yo we was there the k a month ago maybe
I know it was more than a month ago we
were there at 9 00 PM would you leave
I love the like 12. Jesus
[__] she went though she's still working
but like so how about say that that's
the case you got to be like yo if we get
this right it's gonna do well for us
yeah no there's that you know that
happens a lot though it's like me and me
and Rob will like look at each other and
like I like you know we both have that
like look on our face we're like we want
to go home but like we both like are
like very well aware that's like look if
we get this done this [__] is gonna go
right and if they tell us they don't
want it out they're never coming back
you know what I'm saying like where we
spent three hours with your ass like nah
we've had that that's happened a lot to
us like where artists have like come on
and then they'll just be like they'll do
their [__] right and like let's say we
drop it like a month or two later
whatever it is right and then um they'll
be like oh I don't want I don't like
this anymore and then they're like I
want to come redo it I'm like
yeah because it's like I'm like if you
got it you're gonna have to wait like
somebody asked to redo an interview
after it was like a two hour long
interview and I I yeah I didn't like the
way it came off in that let me redo that
a two-hour long interview is Crazy by
the way for them to ask to redo it
it's someone that we're very close
friends with
it it was bald
foreign
I can't wait for you to tell me after
but you let them you would you let
people come back after that or do you be
like nah don't come back no more Freddie
Gibbs what are my best friends oh it's
pretty good we did an interview and he
was like Hey maker we just redo the
whole interview and I was like bro did
you drop it I was like no we I had to
cut out so much and and I get it he was
in a weird place like and he just didn't
want certain [__] in there by the time
no it wasn't the one where he was drunk
okay okay do you cut do you cut up your
interviews a lot like that I'll give
like artist opportunity like you know
like you said like I don't want to like
make people uncomfortable coming over
here so if like there's an artist that
like comes on the show and they're like
hey I said this yeah can you take that
out
I don't care like I'm not gonna be like
nah [__] that you know like the only
time that ever happened was
we had dropped a little pump interview
and
um
y'all chocolate tells me everything I
need to know about this interview yeah
well he tried to like his his little
weenie ass white boy manager I was like
bro you know where the [__] we at bro
come through if you want to talk that
crazy [__] like so what happened was the
interview goes up if they didn't like
the title because I put oh they never
liked the time they never like the
[__] time I put I put like little
pump on new music uh J Cole predicting
his fall off or no not I didn't say his
fall off his career
if if J Cole predicted his career or
something like that it wasn't even like
crazy like flavoring right but they
didn't like the fact J Cole was
mentioned in the in the title so I even
so they had hit me and then they had
like his other manager hit me who like
Works uh I forget what label she works
at but she works with Doug she works
with a lot of people she's like well
respected in the industry so I took it
out of the title right
and then then they had hit me and they
were like because we put the clip up
because we put Clips up right it's like
yo his guy hit me like yo you got to
take that [__] down and I was like or
what it's already up like what you mean
I gotta take it down tell me what's
gonna happen if I don't take it down bro
like what do you what the [__] are you
gonna do bro you see you come back to
the studio we're here all day you know
what I mean and
uh
uh little pump posted my phone number on
his story and said call me
my phone was blowing the [__] up for
like a whole night oh my God
oh my God yeah it was hilarious oh my
God so he'll change your number
obviously yeah yeah I mean I turned my I
just was like I have two phones right so
I just turned that one off
I was driving to Mexico at the time so I
just turned it off and I had all kind I
had all kinds of [__] like weird ass
like pasty white [__] from Germany
sending me nudes and [__] on WhatsApp
like it was [__] weird bro what the
hell it was super weird but you left the
interview up obviously like yeah it's on
there ready to go run it up yeah keep on
go keep watching that I guess right yeah
and it was like a fair interview to
little pump I was like giving them props
and [__] like I see I've watched some of
the clips too like it didn't even seem
like it was like it is what it is it was
funny though it wasn't like a messy
interview it was very just a genuine
conversation about where he's at and
like the whole but you know what people
are delusional people are extremely
delusional so it's like you know if if
he'd have shown some sort of like
humility and like like you know
self-awareness in that interview I feel
like people would be like oh a little
pump you know matured a little but he
was like
I'm rich when I was like did J Cole you
know looking back at y'all's interview
when y'all's interaction do you think he
predicted anything that ended up
happening with your career and she was
like I just know I'm rich and I was like
all right bro well yeah well J Cole J
Cole is also very rich shout out to J
Cole co-owner of the Hornets God damn it
literally co-owner of the Hornets now
that [__] is crazy to me I love that
from you you guys have such a high
output in terms of just like you guys do
a lot right yeah so how many how many
things a week do you feel do you would
you say you filmed
um I mean it could have range for
anywhere like from 15 to 20 I feel like
you know what I'm saying uh depending on
the week that we're having like when
we're on tour we film a lot because
we're doing only freestyles right so
everybody pull up yeah pull up shoot
bang bang boom like today I'll give you
I'll tell you what we're doing today
we're doing uh give me the list John
would you wanna we're doing well he's
John calls at the California Love site
but that's what we're calling it right
so we got a bunch of artists pulling up
today here give me the list it's all
Cali artists yeah yeah so we have reason
we have kembe X we got Simba oh yeah we
got Jason cash okay we got Pac-Man The
Gun Man incognita Kayla James and the
last Stone confirmed today just now oh
Chase someone's gonna be in the cipher
there you gotta be big make sure he's on
time please again
make sure you're uh you know Google in
the politics there oh the politics is
messy on that one no no no no no they
all know about each other I'm not saying
Jay Stone oh okay like that if you ever
come to Cali and you're gonna have like
30 rappers in the building at the same
time just make sure everybody knows
about each other before that happens oh
yeah I'm not saying anybody on that list
you just said is I'm not applying that
to them because they're all very mature
great dudes uh you know yeah but yeah
not uh just you know La can get tricky
oh I know yeah I feel that was the one
thing is like I'm like I can't wear a
Yankee hat out here yeah you can I'm
just yeah I'm just you can wear a Yankee
hat you just can't
go to certain places
wherever you're at you're probably fine
don't tell me that bro I didn't pack no
Yankee
Awards like you're fine like in
Hollywood you're fine in the valley you
just can't go to like South Central
right you really can't just there's like
a a bubble the the like I'm in town
bubble you know I'm in town bubble and
you'll be fine well he got pressed by a
valet once right he got pressed by valet
once again yeah what color was that
like the navy blue one
by the stadium which stadium
oh yeah I mean that makes sense okay see
that's downtown there you go so that's
how we messed up yeah but yeah like I
would say Hollywood to the valley you
know Melrose Beverly Hills Hollywood
you'll be good West Hollywood but yeah
yeah once you start to get into that
downtown
yeah but yeah like I feel like that's
only that's that's the only downside
that I've that I thought out here but
but that's the type of Reason also if
you were to the Rock nation's a great
choice because you can't wear any hat
out here
I think there's two hats that are safe
but every other hat is something right I
I I'm a hat guy right so I don't give a
[__] I just be you know hey man
where are you from now from here buddy
what's up
I pressed recently but it was it wasn't
even like uh I
yeah I got pressed recently a very weird
set of circumstances but it wasn't
because of the Hat I was wearing it was
because I
I was trying to find a place to piss and
I walked down the wrong cul-de-sac
now that that no bathroom nearby where
you have no bathroom new is is mean it's
like where do I go yeah so what like
because again like I said you guys have
so much output yeah yeah how big is the
team like like how many people you got
on the squad that is like helping push
everything out so we got Rob he's like
the main shooter editor we got John he
runs the record label also does like
Talent relations Toby Talent relation
and sales she's a she's a monster
um to the sales yeah like brand deals so
like she'll hook you up with the Puma
deal or whatever yeah she's been
bringing a lot of that we got some we
got a lot of dope stuff on the way with
that uh we got Calvin who does pictures
um we got JV who is kind of like our he
does a little bit of everything like
interning wise and then uh we just
brought my young guy right here JC we
met him at New Orleans last week
um he's from New Orleans
so you know um you know after you meet
him at the route 49 thing yeah yeah
pretty much so and and he's and he's
dope he's good he he works hard so we're
like [__] like we're going from Nola
to L.A let's bring him to LA with us and
you know let's see what he can do so we
have like about like a five-person team
how many uh you did Atlanta you didn't
New Orleans you're in L.A how many
cities are you doing on the tour thing
we've done like we're doing like 10 but
it's definitely Gonna Keep just going up
because like I feel like what I wanted
for on the radar right because we came
up under the New York stuff and
obviously I feel like for me at least I
feel like I've done like almost pretty
much everything I've wanted to do in New
York right I'm always going to be back
in New York always going to do upcoming
New York New York artists because that's
where I'm from that's home but like my
vision for this show is like I want to
be the biggest music platform in the
world right you feel me so we're doing
we're also doing Houston Detroit uh
we're doing the bay uh we're doing
Chicago we're doing DC we're doing Miami
uh we're doing Charlotte North Carolina
what else am I missing I think that's
really that's pretty much it
um and then and then I think we're gonna
work with sleazy world go to bring um to
go to Kansas yeah because he wants to
bring us out to Kansas which is dope
might go to Ohio at some point
and then next year we want to go we're
going to go to Montreal we want to go to
Toronto we want to go to the Canada run
yep want to go do Ghana Nigeria uh we
want to do the UK we want to do London
Spain France Italy Germany so when
you're doing the DJ set thing now right
yeah I I love house music too like so we
kind of are also using that as like a
way to Pivot and kind of
enter in other lanes of music too
because we have hip-hop we have r b we
got some Spanish music that we've been
really pushing out lately
um and but I want to also like I said I
wanted to be the biggest music platform
in the world so I'm definitely trying to
like do DJs as to kind of like get that
European audience too because they're
really into that you got to go to London
man I know that's what yeah that's
that's the goal that's the goal you know
we've had like AJ Tracy dig a d unknown
T gigs like it's the London trip is like
the London trip is just gonna be like me
going back to New York I feel like it's
just like we're just gonna run [__] up
out there and I love the UK culture like
the fact that Central C was able to be
the first so hard first UK artist to do
the double XL cover as far as I'm aware
um yeah I think I mean 21 Savage
how's it going yeah that was a good one
but um but yeah like I love the UK right
now and I think the UK like UK artists
are like really like they're they're
biting a lot of like the American
artists I agree I love the central seat
Dave oh my God one of the best projects
of the year so far we had this
conversation I think on uh I think on
round table people were like oh why do
we feel like male hip-hop artists are
like doing it right now and I'm like I'm
just like I feel like the music just
isn't translating as much to
audiences as well as it did before
because a lot of it maybe is like the
gangster rap part of it I don't know but
I feel like UK artists just take their
crafts very seriously like I think they
take their crafts maybe more seriously
sometimes than American artists at least
upcoming ones I feel like also people
don't give the like the UK drill scene
is kind of what kept that [__] alive you
know what I'm saying yeah like made the
New York [__] kind of I feel like
because it was like Chicago and then UK
and then we got this Brooklyn New York
yeah version of the of the sub genre if
you will all right well look man uh you
got anything else coming up
um man we got the tour um you guys sign
an artist we're working on it we're
working on it we got the on the radar
records uh right now right now we're
doing like projects so I got a bunch of
projects that we got coming out under on
the radar
um we got a lot of singles we gotta huh
yeah I know I'm gonna get to that we got
our first afrobeat single
um that maybe out by the time y'all see
this with this girl fatty she's from
Niger uh incredible incredible Talent
we've worked with her for a little bit
well we went viral with her over in
Africa like a year ago but one of her
performances on my show
um so we got that got a lot of singles
on the way I'm trying to think what else
do we have coming up uh we coming
but yeah I said a bunch of eps we're
going to different cities
um and yeah man I'm just I'm really just
trying to bring on the radar and make on
the radar the biggest and best music
platform that this world has ever seen
I've seen like you know how Americans
how we look at 106 and Park and Rap City
and how we think about that how we
idolize those platforms like I wanted to
be thought I want on the radar be
thought about that but like around the
world yeah well also because the TV [__]
don't matter no more so it's like yeah
it's no one cares yeah TV yeah so I
wanted YouTube's TV bruh YouTube is TV
so if you're not on YouTube you know
what I'm saying but I wanna I wanted to
be the biggest music platform in the
world so that's like that's an angle for
me well [__] man congrats brother you're
on your way man appreciate you pulling
up man yes sir you know what it is hey
this interview is brought to you by our
good Folks at hardean all right shout
out to the hardeen family in Las Vegas
make sure you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection of previous premium cannabis
you can ask for plus when you go to
Hardy in Las vegas.com you can check out
all the other cool stuff they got going
on you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas hardine is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to hardine and when you get
there you tell the wonderful Bud tenders
that I sent you and they're gonna take
care of you Harding underscore Las Vegas
go follow them and uh yeah we got
another interview coming soon